oh my God horrific just like oh God
oh my God the Loch Ness Monster
[Music]
hi I'm Lily James this is snack Wars UK
versus us the lab Bible I feel like I'm
back on Downton Abbey
um okay
[Music]
ah oh
what is this a burger
that smell is just so unique isn't it it
just makes me think of a hangover okay
so here we go this is the um
the sausage and egg McMuffin which is
really good I know it's good
the thing is
I need to have
at least 15 ketchups to eat this and
that's actually way worse than I
remembered
um
[Laughter]
Paradise actually
not sure what's in it against us Cornish
pasty I think there's some potato and
some sort of meat in there yeah
I mean that's better yeah that's better
with more gravy and they both need
seasoning
[Laughter]
UK ding ding ding
this is more like it it's way more like
it Okay so we've got jelly babies and
we've got oh I am gonna like this though
this is an atomic fireball yeah I'm not
sure if this is chewy is this chewing
gum no
oh it's cinnamony
foreign
[Music]
I always say that I love spice and
it's really hot though I mean
I'm not I'm not not loving that one it's
hotter than I remember now however this
this is right up my street I always
remember when my little brother did this
really long Rowing competition and this
is what we were like throwing at him
from the banks because it's got loads of
energy I think I kind of like them all
except for yellow or
these are great definitely this 100 this
is the winner yeah jelly babies are
delicious um
no they've got different shapes oh that
one's crying that's got a hand going
this one
almost
no no I'm not gonna say what I thought
about that they're quite sweet I'm just
sort of line them up an army of babies
um
now I'm covered in Jelly Baby dust
Jelly Baby dust sugar I suppose
oh is it booze yes
so it's an old-fashioned oh yummy
I love an old-fashioned I've only
recently started having old Fashions so
I think I'm going to prefer this this
makes me feel like being a teenager and
just like being puking up over the
toilet
oh
did you do
a third pins and two-thirds lemonade it
was a can it was a cat
really good and now this is the
old-fashioned how did you make the
old-fashioned yeah from a can
yeah okay fine
so good
so good I mean it's not the best
old-fashioned I've ever had I've got to
say
probably one of the worst however I
think it still beats the pims I would
say that's that's America
oh see I like pickles but I've I've
never
um seen them come in this little plastic
bag I kind of like them from a nice
glass jar it says a tart and tangy
flavor so
that sounds delicious
[Laughter]
oh my God horrific just like oh God
oh my God the Loch Ness monster
um I'm just gonna eat this in a not a
kind of phallic way yeah
but I can't I can't split it
[Laughter]
avoiding at all costs
I'm gonna get a cooking show after this
I can tell
um so this is the sour pickle which is
the American and what's this what are
these pickled onions yeah Pub classic
okay
I mean it's so disgusting
I just wish I'd taken a smaller bite
because I like pickles but
it's just too juicy it's juicy oh it's
got like too much body to it um and it
is it is tart and tangy they were
correct
oh now this is embarrassing no no no no
no no
oh there we go
okay
I don't think I'm gonna eat the pickled
onion not to be a spoil sport but that's
just gonna really hang about yeah
um I think
judging by the smell of the sour pickle
wins oh well that's not pickles
absolutely favorite Marmite not peanut
butter and jelly marmite
is just everything to me I don't think I
could live without Marmite and my mum
um
once like the myth of our family is that
when she was young she was really ill
and she was just she was gonna die and
um and Marmite toe saved her life that's
that's the story I don't think she was
gonna die I think I might exaggerated
that but um
this is very cold toast
[Laughter]
um
it's just so delicious do people not get
people don't get Marmite do they ah well
you either love or you hate it
I would even eat this whole all of them
even though they're cold and hardened
not enough I'd put a little bit more
Marmite on even I actually don't know if
I've ever
also why is it jelly it's Jam
peanut butter and jam and interestingly
you don't toast peanut butter and jam
um that's more of a sandwich is it yeah
CBJ Sam with PBJ sandwich yeah they also
do
um Now peanut butter and Marmite no they
don't mix in a jar and it's
delicious it's so good wow
oh it's way better than I thought though
because I like the crunch you used a
crunchy peanut butter yeah
still not good though my my favorite
Marmite wins England for the win
Chris these are like mini Cheddars right
yeah yeah
um
oh great I mean Walkers are good too but
I'm not sure about cheese on you I'm a
prawn cocktail girl
we are good though
I just want to say England because
England wins this is England right
America
I'm thinking of Lays
for America
brand oh my God I'm ashamed okay just
cut that one yeah
ah okay so I
I really don't like these I know that
for sure I think that it's chocolate
sorry America but you are rubbish at
chocolate because I think your chocolate
America is kind of like dry and like
crumbly I don't know if there's too much
sugar in it but nothing beats uh
Cadbury's
laughs
it's like a headache in a mouthful
um
so intense but it's better than I
thought actually
I kind of want to live out the middle
yeah I mean if you feel like how do you
guys do it I do exactly that do you buy
to open then lick it out
I'll take this one away with me too yeah
[Laughter]
this is is so much better than normal
interviews oh my God
crumbly that's the crumbly yeah I'm
right Anna you're all British
horrible chocolate I love being in a
room of English people finally
the K one yeah
yeah God Save the Queen
no I'd rather sit pins in me that's
giving me flashbacks to the toilet so it
Blaster oh yeah
what
no time really no no no